what is the role of military might in
this uh will to power on the national
level well military might's what
ultimately matters as I said to you
before the two building blocks of power
our population size and wealth you
didn't mention military money I did not
no that's right and it's good that you
caught that because if you have a large
population and you're a wealthy country
what you do is you to build a large
military and it's ultimately the size of
your military that matters uh because
militaries fight Wars and if states are
concerned about survival which I argue
is the principal goal of every state in
the International System for what I
think are obvious reasons then they're
going to care about having a powerful
military that can protect them if
another state comes after them what's
not obvious that a large Nation with a
lot of people and a lot of money should
necessarily build a gigantic Army and
seek to attain
superpower like dominant sole superpower
status to military might but you're
saying as you see the world today it has
to be that way yeah I'm arguing it is
obvious if you're a state in the
International System uh do you want to
be weak uh if you live next door to Nazi
Germany or imperial Germany or
Napoleonic France or even the United
States the United States is a ruthless
great power you surely recognize that
and if you're dealing with the United
States of America and you're Vladimir
Putin you want to make sure you're as
powerful as possible so that the United
States doesn't put its gunsights on you
and come after you same thing is true
with China you want to be powerful in
the International System States
understand that and they go to Great
Lengths to become powerful just take the
United States of America when it's
started in
1783 it was comprised of 13 measley
colonies strung out along the Atlantic
Seaboard over time you know the uh
various leaders of the United States
went to Great Lengths to turn that
country into the dominant power in the
Western Hemisphere and then once that
was achieved in 1900 we've gone to Great
Lengths to make sure that there's no
peer uh competitor in the system uh we
just want to make sure that we're number
one uh and my argument is that this is
not peculiar to the United
States uh if I'm China for example
today I would want to dominate Asia the
way the United States dominates the
Western Hemisphere they'd be fools not
to if I were Imperial Germany I'd want
to dominate all of Europe the way the
United States dominated Ates the Western
Hemisphere why because if you dominate
all of Europe assuming your Imperial
Germany or Napoleonic France then no
other state in the area or in the region
can threaten you because you're simply
so powerful uh and again what I'm saying
here is that the structure of the
International System really matters it's
the fact that you're in this anarchic
system where survival is your principal
goal and where I can't know your
intentions right you're another state
I can't know that at some point you
might not come after me you might and if
you're really powerful and I'm not I'm
in deep trouble yeah so some of the
ideas underlying what you've said uh
offensive realism which I would love to
talk to you about sort of the history of
realism versus liberalism but some of
the ideas you already mentioned uh
Anarchy between
states everybody's trying to develop a
military
capabilities uncertainty such an
interesting concept States cannot be
sure that other states will not use
military capabilities against them which
is that's of enormous importance story
and so interesting because you also say
that this makes realist more cautious
and more
peaceful the
uncertainty because of all the
uncertainty involved here it's better to
approach International politics with
caution
which is really interesting to think
about uh again survival most States
interested in survival and the other
interesting thing is you assume all the
states are
rational um which most of the time most
of the
time